the story starts as a woman named
Eleanor awakens in a strange room which
she has never come across across from
her as the manager and architect of this
place Michael shockingly it turns out
that she's dead and now she is in the
afterlife in the afterlife there's the
good place and there's the bad place
luckily she's in the Heavenly afterlife
called the good place after a while
Michael gives her a tour of the good
place neighborhood she'll be residing in
he explains that the good place is
divided into several distinct
neighborhoods with each one containing
exactly 322 residents who have been
perfectly selected to create harmonic
balance every neighborhood is unique
some have cold weather some hot summer
cities summer farms and so on after the
tour Eleanor along with some other
newcomers are made to watch an
informational video in the video Michael
welcomes them to their first day in the
good place afterlife he reveals that
humans are given positive or negative
points by judging each and every action
they make in their lives for instance
throwing trash outside the bin can get
you negative points whereas helping
someone with directions can lead to
positive points after a person dies
their total points are tallied by the
afterlife Architects and only the people
with very high scores are allowed into
the good place moreover everyone in the
good place is awarded with a house of
their own these houses are specifically
designed according to their tastes and
likings in addition they are also given
a soul mate who matches their
personality a person with whom they are
to spend their eternal life together
after the introductory sessions Michael
introduces Eleanor to her soul mate
Chidi who used to be an Ethics Professor
following this he pulls up a video
showing her memories from her time on
Earth it turns out that Eleanor worked
as a lawyer who tirelessly defended
innocent people on death row and
campaigned for human rights this is how
she earned her spot in the good place
however after Michael leaves Eleanor
realizes that something is wrong as it
turns out the memories from the video
are not hers after all in fact the
afterlife Architects had a small mix up
and invited this Eleanor in place of the
real one from the video this imposter
Eleanor had a completely contrasting
life where she made a living by
deliberately selling fake medication to
the sick and elderly she was crass rude
and selfish Eleanor knows that she's
only here because someone with the same
name was sent to the bad place instead
of her shortly after she is introduced
to Janet the source of all information
and knowledge for humans within the good
place Janet is also responsible for
providing the inhabitants with any
object as requested she is basically
Siri who can be used primarily as a
personal assistant by the residents of
the good place next she is also
introduced to some neighbors one of them
is tahani who is outspoken and has
always done charity in her life but
strangely her assigned soulmate is a
monk who has taken an oath to remain
silent in his life that day the good
place is throwing a welcoming party for
all the new residents however Eleanor's
bad nature is soon revealed during the
party she calls the neighborhood tahani
a giraffe and stuffs shrimp up her bra
to steal some food for home the next
morning something very unusual happens
in the neighborhood countless shrimps
are seen flying in the sky giraffes are
running around and even a giant toad is
wreaking havoc it turns out that
everything is a result of the negative
energy Eleanor has been releasing in the
good place taken aback and worried
because of the incident she reveals
everything to her soulmate Chidi she
even begs him to help her be a good
person so that she can remain in the
good place being the good guy that he is
Chidi agrees straight away and starts
teaching her ethics lessons a few hours
later the new residents are called to
assemble for the second day of their
orientation in today's class everyone
will be taught how to fly but since the
neighborhood is in a mess some of them
have to volunteer to clean up the place
taking this is the perfect opportunity
to teach Eleanor about ethics Chidi
mentions both of their names however the
problem is anyone who volunteers will
miss the flying classes Eleanor is
hesitant but she has no choice but to
agree initially she does her job well
and cleans the place well but when she
hears how amazing flying is she hides
the trash inside someone's home and goes
to join the others and just like the
previous incident this this one has
consequences a large trash storm soon
occurs causing Chidi to lose faith in
Eleanor to make matters worse her secret
isn't a secret for long that evening
Eleanor receives an anonymous letter
stating that someone knows she doesn't
belong here panicked she assumes that
her neighbor tahani is the culprit but
just then she receives another message
saying to meet in Town Square Eleanor
quickly follows the instructions and
meets the sender who shockingly is
revealed to beat tahani's soulmate Jason
it turns out he's not a monk and just
like Eleanor Jason was also mistakenly
put in the good place he was a drug
dealing EDM amateur DJ from Florida who
likes to play video games but unlike
Eleanor it's been a walk in the park for
him to hide a secret as he has been
assumed as a mute monk since he entered
the good place together Eleanor and
Jason attempt to stay in the good place
but that proves more and more difficult
as the latter desperately wants to show
his true self one day at an event he
tries to go on stage and reveal
everything but before he does so Eleanor
creates a distraction by ruining a
perfectly made
that one of her neighbors spent three
days working on unfortunately this
creates a large sinkhole in the place
which sends the neighborhood into a
state of panic four days have passed by
but the calamitous sinkhole keeps
becoming larger and larger this makes
Chidi very angry implying that no matter
how many times he gives Eleanor ethics
lessons it's impossible to change her
nature soon their conversation turns
into an argument and for the first time
in her life Eleanor feels guilty hence
she makes a commitment that from now
onwards she will only do good things and
only Tucker until after she died but
it's a start after a couple days of
anxiety Michael still hasn't figured out
who the culprit is he's beginning to
doubt his ability to manage so he
announces that he has decided to retire
everyone is sad to hear this as they
feel Michael has been a good manager the
next day the neighborhood throws a party
before Michael leaves however he asks to
cancel the party as Retirement for a
being like him does not mean that he can
relax in fact retirement for him means
being punished heavily where his soul
will be disintegrated hearing this
Eleanor feels extremely guilty and
decides to come clean that night as
Michael is giving his goodbye speech in
front of the whole town Eleanor gets up
from her seat and confesses to being the
mistake that has been ravaging the
neighborhood as expected this stuns
everyone the next day a train arrives
ready to take Eleanor to the bad place
Chidi Jason and tahani are there to say
their goodbyes however before the train
leaves Michael takes pity on Eleanor and
vouches for her to stay in the good
place claiming that she has improved a
lot and has become good this was proven
when she confessed the truth to save
Michael the problem is that the real
Eleanor has been brought to the good
place to replace the fake one not only
that the superiors have also found out
upon checking that Jason was also
wrongfully admitted to the good place
Michael negotiates with one of his
superiors claiming they both have
changed but the superior decides that at
least two people from here must go to
the bad place he doesn't care which two
following this Eleanor her soulmate
Chidi Jason and his soulmate tahani are
sent to a room to discuss Eleanor
asserts that it has to be her and Jason
since the two were sent here by accident
however Jason is reluctant to leave as
their arguments become more heated and
frustrating Eleanor laments how
torturous this is until Eleanor is
struck with a revelation she deduces
that they are not in the good place at
all and that they are actually in the
bad place in addition they are actually
being tortured by Michael himself she
figures that since they are in this
place they are never happy the four of
them have been torturing each other not
by accident but by Design when Eleanor
confronts Michael and is superior about
her Discovery they begin to laugh evilly
everything was true Soon Michael reveals
everything after being an apprentice in
the bad place for 200 years he was
finally given the chance to design his
own neighborhood but he didn't want to
create a normal bad place rather than
the standard physical tortures the
humans would end up torturing each other
psychologically he believes that mental
torture can be as bad as physical
torture so Michael selected four humans
and his intention was that their
clashing personalities would result in
them torturing each other in various
ways he also reveals that the remaining
318 residents are actually demons
playing the part of humans in Paradise
moreover the real Eleanor is actually
played by another demon actor named
Vicki Eleanor then wonders why tahani
and Chidi are in the bad place as they
are ostensibly good and moral people
however tahani immediately realizes that
she was sentenced to the bad place
because her charitable Deeds on Earth
weren't motivated by genuine altruism
but by a selfish desire for attention as
for Chidi Michael clarifies that it was
due to his rigid and indecisive Behavior
which she refused to correct in any way
despite knowing it made his friends and
family miserable with his scheme exposed
Michael begs his Superior Sean for a
redo by erasing the human's memories and
changing some parameters to which the
latter agrees in a last-ditch effort to
do something Eleanor remembers that the
only non-actor here is the Siri-like
robot Janet hence she rips out a page
from one of chidi's bucks and writes a
message to herself which she then hides
in Janet's mouth Eleanor then taunts
Michael that he will never win but in
reply he simply snaps his fingers and
erases the human's Memories the next
thing we know Eleanor awakens in the
waiting room once again and Michael
takes her around the neighborhood after
taking her back to her house Janet
appears and gives Eleanor the note she'd
written to herself it reads Eleanor find
Chidi in the next scene Eleanor finds
Chidi at the welcoming party she shows
him the paper and explains how she
obtained it but as expected Chidi
doesn't believe her still she convinces
him to come over to her place however
just as she is about to discuss the
matter Michael walks in followed by
several others including tahani Jason
and Eleanor's new soul mate and just
like the previous instance all of them
begin bickering and it doesn't take long
for Eleanor this time to realize that
they are not in the good place worried
Michael erases their minds again and
reboots his plan a third time lying to
his boss Sean that he is still on
attempt number two however no matter how
many times he tries to modify it from
giving humans different soul mates to
altering the environment Eleanor
eventually figures out its true nature
over and over again
[Music]
this is the bad place not only that but
with each reboot the four humans seem to
have better personalities and even find
out about the ruse faster and faster
expectedly Michael grows more frustrated
as time goes on when he launches attempt
at number 802 he goes outside to a
neighborhood meeting where only the
demon actor Vicky is present she
complains that everyone is sick of the
constant reboots so much that they often
can't remember what their jobs even are
when Michael tries to clarify Vicki
mentions that he has lost control of the
experiment so the other demons have gone
on strike she then presents the list of
their demands which includes her taking
over the next reboot Michael is outraged
and swiftly refuses the demand but Vicky
blackmails him by saying that if he
doesn't comply she will reveal the 800
reboots to his Superior Sean this will
result in him getting retired for sure
Michael is visibly frustrated but just
then an idea strikes his mind he goes to
Eleanor's house where she Chidi and
tahani are and Jason joins them
seemingly once again they already know
they are in the bad place Eleanor says
they figuring out the puzzle of the good
place so they're winning and he's losing
however Michael says that he wants to
team up with them he details his plan he
will reboot the neighborhood but
secretly leave the four humans memories
intact then they will pretend to
emotionally suffer for a long time
without realizing this is a fake good
place if they refuse the experiment will
be deemed a failure and everything will
go downhill Michael himself will be
retired and burned eternally while the
humans will be shifted to traditional
physical torture Michael also claims
that he can get the four and himself
into the real good place if they succeed
in their plan they agree but Eleanor
adds a condition as a member of the team
Michael must also participate in chidi's
ethics classes next to the neighborhood
is again rebooted with Vicky taking over
as the main caretaker for the next few
months the four humans pretend to suffer
emotionally and not know about the fake
good place every day they meet Michael
in secret where they are also joined by
Janet whose purpose is to serve the
humans there they are taught ethics by
Chidi it is difficult for Michael to
understand the concepts owing to the
fact that he is an immortal being whose
only purpose is to torture humans he
confides to Eleanor that he finds it
hard and wonders how she was able to
improve so much Eleanor states that
whenever she did a bad thing she'd hear
a little voice telling her it was wrong
when she would do good it would go away
and she would feel better Michael takes
comfort in this time passes and one day
Michael receives a surprise visit it's
his Superior Sean congratulating him on
the success of his experiment and
promotes him he reveals that based on
records the four humans have been
enduring similar torture like the ones
in the actual bad place Michael then
pretends to reveal to the four humans
that they're in fact in the bad place
however much to their shock Sean informs
them that because the experiment is a
success they want to study everything
that happened here the four humans will
now be transferred to a traditional
section of the bad place to be tortured
there their brains will be studied as
expected the group is devastated in
particular Eleanor feels like Michael
has betrayed them however he claims that
he didn't know anything about this
Eleanor starts to be raiding him as they
are now doomed but Michael says that
there is one solution they have to
escape the good place and for that they
need to meet the judge who lives in a
portal in the middle of the bad place
then all the humans have to individually
back up their claims that they are
worthy of living in the good place the
humans are skeptical about the idea but
since they have no other options they
agree next Eleanor Chidi tahani Jason
Michael and Janet are on a train on
their way to the bad place headquarters
after a long journey they make it to the
residents of the immortal the
all-knowing judge Jen and try to
convince her that they are worthy of
being in the good place however the
judge reveals that no human has been
accepted to the good place in the past
531 years shocked to learn this Michael
argues that the point system is
inherently flawed as the rise of
globalization and Industrial capitalism
has simply made it impossible for any
human to be ruled good enough after a
lot of arguments the judge agrees that
there is a flaw in the system which they
need to fix immediately to solve this
she conducts a meeting and summons some
others to discuss the matter the team
then makes a proposal in the current
system people get one shot at life get
evaluated and get a final Destiny but in
Michael's fake good place the four
humans had hundreds of lives because of
the reboots and through them they got
better and better hence they proposed
that the life humans have on Earth will
be considered not the test of one's
ultimate Destiny but just a starting
class at death the human's point total
will give them a place to begin all of
them will go through a test a simulated
environment like Michael's neighborhood
set up by two architects one from the
good place and one from the bad place
they will make a scenario which exposes
the person's moral shortcomings at the
end of the scenario The Architects will
sit down with them and evaluate what
they need to work on and then they'll
get rebooted Dana member asks how that's
going to help since they'll forget
everything when rebooted Eleanor
explains that what they discussed will
remain with them like a little voice in
their head humans will go through it as
many times as needed in each reset life
most people will improve until they are
the best versions of themselves some
people won't but MO most well which will
allow them into the good place impressed
by the elaborate plan the judge agrees
to the new system much to the human's
Delight to kick start the system at
first they need to identify the first
thousand humans to be tested in the next
scene the first batch of test
neighborhoods are up and running as
Eleanor and her group are passing by the
crowded place they suddenly hear the
sound that the system makes when someone
passes the test for the good place
excited they ask Michael who passed and
the latter replies that it's the four of
them the judges decided that they don't
need to take any tests since they have
saved More Humans by proposing this new
system and that's worth a lot of points
after some time a golden balloon
descends from the sky to send them to
the real good place the four humans are
accompanied by Janet and Michael with
the latter saying that he wants to
travel for a bit soon the balloon takes
off a few moments later the squad
finally makes it to the good place the
good place committee welcomes everyone
as Heroes and tells Michael to come
along with them as they want to bring
him in as an official good place
architect the humans go through a portal
to their welcome party which has
decorations and memorabilia relating to
all four of their personal tastes Janet
also reveals there are two green doors
there which are all over the good place
through which a person can go to visit
any time or place real or imaginary
hearing this Jason dashes off to fulfill
his lifelong dream of racing go-karts
with monkeys on the other hand Chidi and
Eleanor run into the legendary
philosopher hypatia of Alexandria Chidi
ecstatically tries to ask her about her
work but she's tongue-tied not really
capable of any more than small talk she
then tells them that things in the good
place are not quite what they seem in
theory the good place is a perfect
Paradise where all your needs and
desires are instantly mad but eventually
the novelty of that pleasure wears out
on the mind turning it into mush hypatia
then reveals that she doesn't even
remember the work she is famous for on
Earth the honey sees for herself what
hypatia has revealed as she socializes
with the other residents who are in even
worse shape as they're all lethargic
hedonists who can only speak in
monotonous tones when interacting with
her everyone has been become a bunch of
unfeeling zombies who are unbearably
bored after having experienced literally
everything now they have nothing more to
do but wait out the rest of Eternity
meanwhile Michael is given a nice robe
into Metal by the committee they also
have him sign a big scroll that makes
him an architect and as soon as it is
signed the committee members scoop it up
and dash out of the room saying that
Michael's now officially in charge of
the good place after a while the squad
regroups Jason who has just returned
reveals that go-kart racing against
monkeys got boring real fast proving the
good place is incapable of keeping
anyone happy forever discussing this
they realize that's why the committee
quit they knew they had a problem but
couldn't think of any way to fix it
except more ways to fulfill desires just
then Eleanor comes up with a theory she
says that every human is a little bit
sad all the time because they know they
will die but that knowledge is What
Gives Life Meaning however here in the
good place they don't have that hence
during a party when all the residents of
good place have gathered Eleanor and her
group suggest their idea of having the
option to leave the Place forever if
someone wants to go they can leave
through a door but this will mean that
they will never be able to return
hearing this the crowd stares for a
while but then erupts in shears they
absolutely love the idea and start
partying after a few weeks we get to
know that the system is working Michael
and Janet have regular meetings with
judge Jan and The Architects on how
things are going and while there are
some bumps in the road millions of
humans are being properly sent to their
appropriate Destinies meanwhile those in
the good place are making the choice to
leave once they are ready the first from
Eleanor's Squad to make the decision is
Jason he's won a perfect game in Madden
NFL after thousands of tries Andy's
reached the end of his goals in the
afterlife he emotionally tells his
friends of the decision and then throws
a big farewell party before going out
meanwhile tahani has been spending her
afterlife mastering every practical
skill she can think of she knows that
going through the door would be a waste
of all the knowledge she's gained so she
decides to apply it all towards becoming
an architect like Michael Chidi and
Eleanor have been happily going through
the works of famous philosophers and
hanging out with their friends and
family members who have made it to the
good place however one day Eleanor finds
out that Chidi is also ready to go and
becomes determined to keep him with her
but when she realizes that it would be
selfish to force him to stay she
tearfully bids him goodbye on their last
night together Chidi reassures Eleanor
that he'll always be with her in a way
when the next morning comes she wakes up
alone in bed with a final parting gift
from her soul mate Eleanor feels ready
to leave but Michael also wants to go
through the door as he feels he's
accomplished everything and no longer
knows what to do anymore now that the
judges stopped their meetings due to how
well the new system works but as the
last door wasn't made for him Eleanor
gets an idea she convinces judge Jen to
let Michael go to Earth and live as a
human being and in no time the former
architect of the bad place is turned
into a human before leaving he promises
Janet that they'll see each other again
in his new human life Michael makes
friends makes mistakes learns from them
and experiences new things a few weeks
later Eleanor who now feels whole and
complete shares one last Margarita and
chats with Janet the show ends as the
two hug and Eleanor finally goes through
the last door subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching